[Music]
[Applause]
there's just something really satisfying
about skipping a rock if you've ever
skipped one five or six times you might
find yourself taking a little more
seriously see if you can get seven
eight nine consecutive skips turns out
some people take stone skipping
very seriously and actually compete to
see who can skip the most or who can
skip the farthest
the current world record for most
consecutive skips
is probably higher than you think try
counting the skips in this footage of
the world record just
don't blink did you catch it that was 88
skips here's the amazing thing models
actually project the limit
could be a lot higher than that today
we're going to explore what that limit
might be and why approaching or even
exceeding it
could be almost impossible
to find out what it takes i skipped
stones with the world record holder
what was that seven eight you know the
odd thing is i never
count are you serious you never count i
don't
talk to fluid dynamics with a physicist
it hits the water
and this back end sort of creates a uh
wave and so the
tone tends to rise up over that wave
that it creates
and that's what allows it to get a lift
force that gets it back in the air again
before the next impact and over and over
again
and brought both of them together oh
gorgeous
to see if we can figure out how a
world-class stone skipper
gets so many touches on the water and
what the limit might actually be
so we're here today with kurt steiner
he's the world record holder in stone
skipping specifically
most consecutive skips on the water and
how many skips
was that it was 88.
that's so remarkable i can't even like
i i'm not a really talented stone
skipper but you know if i find myself at
a lake with some stones i will do some
skipping i think the most i've ever done
is like 13 or 14
and like that makes me really really
happy and proud so 88 is like
how it is what makes you happy that
counts more
but i think we can get that number up a
bit we flew steiner and a couple boxes
of rocks to utah
where he gave me some lessons on extreme
stone skipping
steiner makes it look easy but a good
skip is more than just how hard you
throw a stone
or at which angle in fact it all starts
with the stone
itself okay that was closer to like 15
16. i was going to say 15.
all right 15. all right so the most i've
ever skipped before this
is around 14 15. right and here on my
second throw
i hit around 1415 which tells me there's
a lot to do
with the rock you're using steiner's
stones
made a huge difference
the worst rock in this box is better
than the nicest rock i've ever skipped
steiner like a lot of top skippers is
very particular about his stones
he collects his from lake erie a few
hours from his home in pennsylvania
a lot of questions to what kind of rock
is best right the general category i use
is just how many
sides is it steiner isn't just an expert
stone skipper
he's an expert stone picker too this one
is pretty similar to the one i would
have set the record with
he uses different shapes for different
skips and different conditions people
like triangles
i used to like triangles but they just
chew up the water too much
you're always kind of weighing how much
irregularity is in my rock against
how hard am i throwing it against
what water am i throwing it onto steiner
also showed me how to hold the stone for
maximum skipping
the first thing you ever want to do is
determine which side is going to be down
right and
you generally want to go with the
flatter or slightly rounded if it's
cupped
or jagged put that up especially you
want to look at the outer edge because
the stone almost never touches except
around
a half inch around the edge but as i
soon found out
there's a lot more to skipping than just
picking a good stone
steiner uses a variety of grips and
stances
for things like distance power and
number of skips
that's a high spin throw and then
there's one here where you're a little
closer to the water that's a good way to
get a lot of power in real close
he's got a classic low skimming toss and
an unusual
overhand swing but basically you're just
going to try to
swap the water as hard as you can with
the rock as flat as possible
he showed me how to get a little more
whip on my skip
oops lesson number one throw hard
you've got a lot more strength than
you're using he suggested trailing my
hand
yeah and don't start pivoting your waist
around and your shoulder round
until that left leg is a good foot out
in front of you
if you drag your arm right right you see
what i mean
you're almost opening up into the throw
it'll
tension up across here and then
essentially your hand is catching back
up to the rest of your body and will
snap out better
all right let's give that a shot
okay it that actually
looked a little better to me so now the
third part is where it comes together
here
that's where you've got to hit your
target next kurt had me aim for a first
touch
closer to the shoreline did you notice
how when you through the rock the longer
it stays in the air
the more it will roll over on its side
that is always happening you can
minimize that obviously by lessening the
time in the air
which is one reason you want to hit
close so we're going to be focusing on
three things on this throw based on
kurt's feedback one i'm going to be
delaying the start of my throw so i can
utilize more of my biomechanics two i'm
gonna try to throw it hard
and three i'm gonna try to make contact
with the water really close to myself
there it is
so that looked like high teens to me
immediate immediate improvement
and that was your first try yes yeah and
yeah
that's so cool
every throw is a complete new puzzle
so how is it that someone like steiner
can skip stones
so many times
to find out we asked tad trusket who
runs the splash lab at utah state
university
in logan yeah splash lab welcome thanks
you've got
a lot of really cool stuff in here yeah
it looks like junk but we're using all
of it
yes it's a real lab and the work they do
there is
amazing and then this tank here where i
shot bullets into it for my
uh thesis my phd thesis shot bullets
into this yeah yeah absolutely uh they
were
modified 22 bullets is that what that
hole is yeah yeah it's where we missed
but that's a misfire but yeah to study
stone skipping truscut and his team
recorded steiner hurling stones into a
tank
at thousands of frames per second to
figure out how many skips are possible
you have to first understand just how a
skip works
here's what happens so you have the
stone it's in your hand
and you throw it and as you do that you
release it off of your fingers
and that causes it to have some spin so
this spin is really important we call it
gyroscopic stabilization it essentially
holds the attack angle of the
of the rock with respect to say the
surface of the water
so then when you hit the water it
deforms the water and pushes a wave out
in front of it
but the velocity of the stone is much
faster than the wave that it creates and
so it ends up rising up
on that wave that it created and this
causes a little lift force
the rock is able to go back into the air
and then back down and so this happens
over and over and over again for a good
rock skip right
and that gyroscopic stabilization is
what keeps that attack angle correct
and friction is really the only other
thing that's like reducing your ability
to keep going
the splash lab isn't the only one
studying stone skipping
a group of french scientists first
figured out a model for ideal skipping
in 2004.
these researchers in france found out
that the optimal
angle for a disc to skip on the water's
surface is about 20 degrees
for both the attack angle and also that
velocity vector
that coupled with um you know how how
fast
it is thrown as well as how much
gyroscopic stabilization it has
sort of set up the problem to find out
what the maximum number of skips you can
get or the number of skips you'll get
based on what that spin rate is and what
that velocity is and that
uh impact angle now you might think that
studying stone skipping
is a bit frivolous but truscuit says
there are practical applications
yeah definitely so a spacecraft that was
proposed that would bounce off the
atmosphere as it kind of came back
towards earth
and use that to keep itself out you know
if you want to land on say the moon of
titan you may want to
you may want to come in for a soft
landing knowing how skipping works might
be a great way to do that
to figure out how steiner skips so many
times truscan and his lab also went into
the field to gather data on his arm
speed
and the rotation of the stones
all right i think that was
it dude steiner's maximum speed is
around 50 miles an hour
his world record skip was calculated at
43 miles per hour
but he also has years of experience even
his dud throws put my best efforts to
shame
but could someone best his record i've
seen one or two people who have
a technique that could maybe beat that
but it's almost impossible
[Laughter]
[Music]
now you might remember from our previous
episode on the fastball that pitchers
are about maxed out on speed
at just over 100 miles per hour trust
could apply that metric to stone
skipping
and came up with some amazing
calculations
a really safe place on our chart puts
you around 93 mile an hour
throw because these are a little heavier
than a than a baseball
and um and they're a little they have a
bigger radius which makes their moment
of inertia larger so you need a little
more energy in that side of it
so 93 miles an hour is about where
you're topping out
you're going to have about 2 800 to 3
000 revolutions per minute
and if you can get there that's of close
to 164 joules
you're going to probably get close to
300 350 skips
350 yeah under the current id
yeah is that even possible 300
already just seems ridiculous right
i don't even know who could count that
like i couldn't count 10 today
steiner thinks the limit is probably
closer to 200.
that's what the number says i'd like to
go test it trusket and other scientists
have modeled their projections using a
perfectly round disk
but as steiner showed me there are no
uniform stones
because mother nature never sees fit to
make two of the same thing
i have to get on her about that so
skipping a stone might seem like a
simple thing
but it's actually this beautifully
complex mix of skill
athleticism and fascinating physics it's
such a miracle to me what's going on
you know it's just this weird dance of
water and stone and air so will we ever
see 300 consecutive skips
or 350 that's a good question
it'll probably take someone with a major
league caliber arm and
kurt steiner's devotion but what we're
seeing these days
from the world's top skippers is already
almost
impossible
you